Awesome work if you got this one right. First we distribute a negative 1 to each
of the terms, so we change the signs. Next we combine our like terms and regroup
them in our next line. 6a to the 4th, and 6a to the fourth make 12a to the 4th.
A squared and a cubed just need to be listed down here. Notice that I switched
the order of them, that's okay. I know 2 plus 1 is the same thing as 1 plus 2.
We can use the commutative property of addition to rewrite our expressions. The
order doesn't matter. And finally on the end, we have negative 2. If you're
wondering why I switched the order of these, it's because we usually have the
powers decrease as we list the terms. We have a to the fourth, a to the cubed, a
squared, there's no a term here and then our constant. If you're having any
trouble with adding or subtracting polynomials, that's a great time to ask some
questions in the forum. We love to hear from you. Maybe you're wondering about
like terms, or maybe you're wondering about intergers. If so, let us know.